Tony Romo is the newest CBS sports
analyst you tell her on here it's kind
of like a little family speaking of
family Tony and his wife of six years
Candace just welcomed a new addition oh
it's super exciting you know my third
boy you know so building my own
basketball team here I'm getting close
I think the wife might want to stop at
this point but well push her again in
the year to once they hold that baby and
that baby grows up a little bit they
wanted to hold that baby again that's
just how wives are in moms et spoke to
the 37 year old former Dallas Cowboys
quarterback at the CBS NFL media day on
Wednesday the proud dad opened up about
the joys of raising his sons the other
boys are five and three right now so
they're real fun and they like playing
wrestling around dad it's a special time
they want to play everything from swords
to Legos to basketball the golf football
the NFL star turned TV commentator also
dished on his pal Justin Timberlake
rumor has it that the singer could
return to the Super Bowl halftime stage
in 2018 I think if they got Justin that
would be a home run I think he's one of
the rare guys that everyone thinks is
great he's super talented and while the
halftime performers have yet to be
announced
Tony revealed JT does have new music on
the way which could help with booking
the gig I know Justin's excited about
he's gonna kill it gonna be a great